As far as the most infamous leader in the world right now,...
...Russian President Vladimir Putin flies around in style.
The man has got his own Ilyushin IL-96-300.
This ended up costing a comparatively reasonable,...
...by standards of other world leaders, sum of 500 million dollars.
This plane has all sorts of special amenities, including an office space, a gym,...
...and one particular Putin favorite, golden toilet seats.
The Saudi Arabian royal family...
...has one of the most impressive planes in the entire world.
That would be the Airbus A380, which is worth a big-time budget of 502 million dollars.
This is the plane that famously features its own golden throne...
...in the middle of the aircraft.
This was designed with only one thing in mind: to create a flying palace...
...that shows the family's decadent wealth in every single inch.